on va on va vous faire mentir un petit
peu quand qu'on va baisser la lumière on
ne bouge pas attention
[Applaudissements]
voilà on va faire donc l'interview
mensonge vous allez répondre sans dire
la vérité c'est que j'ai vu c'est pas
une pratique habituelle mais donc vous
mentez c'est un jeu de l'esprit est ce
que c'est vrai que vous êtes resté très
copain avec elie alors il faut que je
m'en attendais il faut que je vois là je
me mets dans la peau d'un monteur s est
pas faite à l'achat alors pour répondre
et pour mentir je dirais je ne pardonne
pas et lits d'accueil salle voilà si je
devais dire la vérité je n'en ai pas la
vérité c'est l'interview manceau faisait
tout [ __ ] en l'air et je suis métisse
besoin d'un côté l'autre ici voulu
déséquilibrer je me disais 'j'ai mots en
plus non non je suis verso seulement
maîtrise alors bon comme giscard
d'estaing giscard d'estaing et mozart
aussi ah ouais ça vous fait de quoi
parle à vous occuper de ça aussi vous
avez réussi à l'écologie je m'intéresse
à tous et mon voeux disait qu'après
carnet vous annoncez ballon sur douala
et vous alors on continue fait sens que
vous êtes un fan de la gaffe vincent
lagaf non c'est vrai que je
il faut que je bande basse et l'internet
avaient dit qu'on n'y arriverait pas
avec lui la cité le mensonge peut
essayer et
une réponse directe
je suis un fan de la gaffe oui ou non
ils n'arrivent pas à mendier et dit non
mais c'est surtout difficile de dire de
dire qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas c'est
vachement difficile si arthur sébastien
hardy sont
tellement fort bien
ben bella gaffe je les rencontre et on a
discuté
il a une discussion d'arriver en arrive
à parler bon bah c'est sûr tel mail non
il va pas tout écrire de la poésie il va
pas de pair un alexandrin teiki pont
alexandra mais euh bon paraît un peu
direct donc je dirais non
ben oui vous êtes fans oui c'est un
mensonge je sais pas mais c'est un
mensonge et cindy a pas de problème oui
vous êtes français pour l'interview
mensonge prenait là moi je suis anti
aulas
si l'on ne sait pas non non vous avez
raison vous avez raison et je voyais
merci non mais si vous est ce que l on
continue l'interview de mensonge donc
d'ailleurs en bas de l'écran il ya écrit
interview - sens donc il n'y a pas deux
est ce que vous êtes accro au pognon
comme on le dit c'est à dire vraiment un
prog a
fini à dix était juif et moi de noir
enfin bon si vous c'est bien la
réputation vous avez
venons de vous je trouve ça étonnant
quand même enfin
c'est quand même bouquet de payer ce
soir et on ne sait pas combien
d'ailleurs mais alors par rapport à ça
je dirais bon effectivement un noir qui
gagnent plus du smic ça paraît être un
scandale alors là oui
bah je gagne je leur c'était quoi la
question faut que la question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes accro pognon
je fais pas de publicité je ne vends pas
je ne viens pas vendre systématiquement
des produits à la télévision je suis
plutôt là pour parler un petit peu de de
certaines convictions donc je sais pas
si je suis vraiment un homme a tiré par
le par le pognon je le suis certainement
comme tout le monde pas plus pas moins
c'est génial non mais moi je me régale
parce que cette interview mon sens j'en
ai déjà fait chez x 7,8 fois et vous
êtes le premier qu'il n'y arrive pas et
c'est quelque part c'est bien je trouve
vous n'arrivez pas en fait vous répondez
franchement ben je mens mais en même
temps une action série 3-2 pour moi pour
moi les interviews mensonge à la
télévision c'est tout il n'y a pas
besoin de le préciser c'est
évidemment c'est en permanence nous
allons sortir la france du marasme qu'il
y a trop de problèmes ici il faudrait
que je m'exprime comme ça pourrait
effectivement joué le jeu à fond voilà
c'était pas mal
c'est vrai alors on va faire plus ça
parce que sinon on n'y arrivera jamais
est ce que c'est vrai vous avez un sexe
énorme
alors si on est toujours dans le cadre
du jeu tout jouer alors dans le cadre du
jeu
j'ai
reçu je refuse je refuse d'appuyer
encore sur un vieux poncifs qui une fois
de plus sa voix je n'impose à tout le
monde la question oui ça pour mon nom
mais attention tu irais je me posais
albert mais je connaissais la réponse
bancaire
non non non non non on est pas mal non
non non je n'ai pas parlé que de mettre
en paroles mais c'est vrai que je
précise à ce moment là si vous l'aimez
niveau de cette question je précise que
ça appuie encore sur un vieux poncifs du
[ __ ] bien membré on reconnaît c'est
plutôt flatteur belge est parano je sais
pas du tout à ça non non c'est pas de la
paranoïa non mais j'essaye de wii plus
ciblé le laisser dire que tous les noirs
n'ont pas obligatoirement des grosses
beats et ça c'est dommage bâtard et et
moi
je trouve que j'ai trop entendu
effectivement cette blague ayant volé
néron
mais bon bon je pense que c'est aussi
mon rôle de dire que c'est un peu chiant
alors bon ça peut paraître un peu
militantisme un peu foireux je suis
d'accord bon mais en même temps comme on
n'est pas nombreux à s'exprimer bon bah
je la gare lorsque la preuve que ce
n'était pas une question qui était
réservé à vous c'est que je voulais vous
demander si vous ouvrez vraiment une
boîte échangiste abreu a ça par contre
c'est faux
ça fera plaisir même si en bois très
bien merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]